hello - we said that you'd give me a
great deal of thought yes I have I've
been wrestling with this for some time
I've been a member of the Conservative
Party since 1990 I've stood numerous
times been elected many times as a
Conservative member of parliament but
I've concluded that I just think it is
too much of a risk for the economy if we
are going to find ourselves crashing out
without a deal at the end of 2020 and I
don't think that the Conservative Party
is being straight with the British
people as to the choices that we face
and the implications of those choices do
you feel as strongly as Ian Austin does
who was a former Labour MP about Jeremy
Corbyn being in number two it's not for
me about who is in number ten rather
than I sherry in Austin's view about
Jeremy Corbyn it is about the policy
that is being pursued and I think it is
reckless I think it is irresponsible and
I think a conservative majority and I'm
really regretting having to say this a
conservative majority will pursue
policies that are going to be
detrimental to large numbers of people's
jobs and livelihoods and for me being a
conservative is about a strong economy
it is about being pro-business it is
about bringing down trade barriers not
putting them up and I am very worried
well I think I think the the Prime
Minister the Prime Minister's approach
to brexit when he says and there's this
important point I don't think is
necessarily been fully appreciated here
is that the government is saying we are
going to negotiate a free-trade
agreement during the implementation
period and we're not going to extend the
implementation period comes to an end at
the end of 2020 there was for now
well but they have said they're not
going to extend yeah as we know the
Prime Minister said lots of things yeah
but I don't believe that politically he
has got the space that the conserve the
wider conservative party would let him
extend even if he wanted to and there's
no sign that he does want to now every
single expert says you cannot get
free-trade agreement done in 11 months
it takes three years
at least and if he is saying we are not
extending and he is promising
we are not extending the clear
implication for that is at the end of
2020 we leave on WTO terms and that
would be a disaster for large parts of
our ability you say the Prime Minister
would not agree if he was here I mean
and a lot of people watching this
morning would say that you were
disciplined for breaking the rules and
now you're just being richer and you're
taking your ball home and you're being
on national international telly and
taking it out on the prime minister look
I understand why the Prime Minister
didn't give me the whip back because he
knew that I had strong differences with
him on this policy and you know it is a
matter of principle and I've I have in
the longest few months I've consistently
made the case about why No Deal is bad
for the country it's bad for your view
is it will mean that we are
significantly poorer than we are and I
will argue the case and we've listened
and you've made your point the point is
you still despite that wanted to stand
as a conservative your local party
wanted you to stand as a conservative in
the prime minister said absolutely no
way how disappointed are you that the
Conservative Party is not a broad enough
church to take in your views as well
well as to whether I was going to stand
I when I voted against the the whip on
the 3rd of September I knew what the
implications were previously I'd fought
off a deselection
attempt well of course yeah at that
point we had a different Prime Minister
in a different policy but look you know
I've been a conservative
essentially all my adult life I've been
a Conservative MP for 14 and a half
years but look I have in recent weeks
looked at the way that the Conservative
Party policy has evolved and I you know
and I really don't want to be in this
position but I can only reach the
conclusion that if implemented which is
what a conservative majority would
enable it to do we will be pursuing I
still refer to we the conservative we
would be pursuing a policy that is bad
for the country bad for the British
people would make us poorer and I think
that would be a massive
steak is a mess a mistake for the
Conservative Party but the Conservative
Party has if you like made its bed and
it's got to sleep in it but it would be
a massive mistake for the country and
that is why yesterday I resigned my
membership of the Conservative Party and
announced that I was astounded well it's
of course it's yeah I felt all about
that
I think the Conservative Party has done
a lot of goods but I don't believe that
it would be the right thing for the
country in this general election and I
and I think the Conservative Party has
I'm afraid fundamentally changed it's
abandoned a lot of its traditions is
moving in a particular direction and I
think there are a lot of if you like let
me look at myself as a conservative
voter there are a lot of contradiction
all conservative voters like me who fail
homeless now in my case I'm going to run
as an independent but I think you're a
lot of those voters are looking for
example the Liberal Democrats this time
in a way that they've never done before
and I think many of them will vote for
the Liberal Democrats and when you look
at the risks of I'm afraid of what a
Conservative government would bring I
think they're right to look at the
Liberal Democrats can you look at
yourself in the mirror on the 13th of
December when Jeremy Corbyn is
potentially in number 10 Downing Street
and accept that it's because of people
like you that Boris Johnson is no longer
there I will do everything I can to
oppose Jeremy Corbyn being Prime
Minister but I think we have to look at
this and say yeah it's a choice for the
country really between a hold brexit or
jeremy corbyn we really ought to be able
to do better than that as a country and
well I don't believe that they are and
the bridge well the British people have
the opportunity of voting for members of
parliament or voting for candidates of
the centre ground now whether they are
independents or whether they are Liberal
Democrats or whether they are you know
some of the sensible conservatives we've
got all the sensible labour people that
we've got and what I would urge people
to do is to look very closely at who are
the sensible pragmatic candidates there
that will not either allow that hard
No Deal brexit nor allow our Jeremy
Corbyn to be
you're turning your face away but it is
a two horse race and you could well be
responsible for Jeremy Corbyn being in
number 10 down history because you're
saying go Troy I'm saying a conservative
majority would be damaging for this
country because of the policy on brexit
is reckless it is irresponsible it's not
in the best traditions of the
Conservative Party and I think if I can
play a role in giving a voice to that to
articulating that and provide an
opportunity in one constituency for
people to vote for me but also to look
more widely across the country at voting
for sensible candidates then I think we
can move forward in a sensible way okay
very briefly at we're out of time your
thoughts very quickly on Jeremy Corbyn
being described as self-obsession and
onanism being accused of that
well the Prime Minister users colorful
language it's not the language I would
particularly used but I do believe that
Jeremy Corbyn would be a disasterous
Prime Minister